the next query really is regarding a
woman who is pregnant or is nursing
breastfeeding nursing rearing the
children why they
Exempted according to the words of the
Quran in Surah Bak chapter number two
verse number 185 that if a person is ill
and traveling he can make up his
prescribed periods of day of fasting
later on so most of the FAS most of the
scholars they say that these women who
are pregnant and breastfeeding they come
under the category of those who are ill
so therefore if they want they can
abstain from fasting but there are
clearcut say in which the prophet has
Exempted these women from fasting
mention
in
MA Hadith number 1667 that our beloved
Prophet says the obligation for a person
to fast and part of the prayer to have
been lifted from a traveler and the
obligation for fasting has been lifted
from a lady who's pregnant and with best
feeding our beloved Prophet malli wasam
also said it's mentioned
in in the book of fasting had number 2-
74 that Allah subhana tala has relieved
The Traveler from fasting and half his
prayer and Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
relieved the pregnant woman and the
woman whose breastfeeding from fasting
So based on these two Hadith also so
it's clearcut that the pregnant women
and the women who are breastfeeding they
have been Exempted and The Logical
reason that one can think is because
when a lady she's pregnant or she's
breastfeeding the food she eats is not
only for herself it's for herself as
well as the baby she's carrying or the
baby she's feeding so but natural if her
fasting makes it difficult for her or
become difficult for a baby then she's
Exempted from fasting but if she's in
the early stage of pregnancy and if she
feels or she's breastfeeding and if she
feels that fasting will not cause any
damage to her health and will not cause
the damage to the baby then she should
fast if she has a doubt if she can do it
with hardship as long as there's no
damage to herself to her health and the
baby she has option to fast not to fast
but if it's causing damage to her health
or the baby it becomes Haram for her to
fast because
Allah subhana wa taala does not want to
lay a burden more than what a person can
bear and in this regard that is the
reason Allah has Exempted them later on
when they're healthy when they stop
breastfeeding or when the pregnancy ends
after P nle bleeding then they have to
make up for the F they have missed
before the next